hey what's up everybody its Anna Mack
here for anime uproar and this is rant
cafe number 35 yet another rant cafe
live here every Thursday 5 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time anime podcast 4d ages
welcome everyone in the chat everyone
joining me today we got anime recon we
got Briggs the other guy who's not
afraid to show his face and we got soul
maka what's up boys
not much very good
we're good we're good yeah I'm glad to
help you guys here and what we're gonna
be talking about this week is anime that
will change your life animate them
really spoke to us that inspired us to
you know really see things differently
in life motivated us in some way and
really got us to love anime and to think
about life life in a different way I got
many examples of this and also I was
thinking about you know if we have a
good conversation here today and I get
some cool ideas
I might make a special video about these
type of anime eventually because I've
been thinking about it for a while so
yeah if you guys would like to see
something like that do let me know down
in the comments or in the chat or
whatever I sounds pretty cool about cool
idea yeah because I thought like little
anime lovers here so why do we really
like anime is it just for the app she
like recon or is there something off a
man pull out a show me yeah you pull out
the [ __ ] on me cuz I love you oh yes
used to understand yes she inspired him
inspired me tell you what exactly why it
gave me a better understanding of the
female [ __ ] better I don't know I just
like it I don't know
and by the way guys we also got oh who's
this who's this is that an otaku who's
an assassin an assassin with a weird-ass
skull mask
he's not Knox might be joining us
it's he is he where is he we don't know
we don't know well let him set up the
point is yes Knox talk who might be
joining us today he is another quality
youtuber you can drag them all link in
description he makes really hilarious
content like sarcastic anime trailers
for attack on Titan mighty rocket eating
a lot of really hilarious stuff and
however his German counterpart nuke
stock who is far superior but I don't
speak German so I thank you thank you
that it what's up man not much evening
welcome bro however your your screen
looks like you are Kudo beauty from my
dear academia right now don't know why
that is try to set it up so you have an
avatar so like if you turn off your
webcam
it's your avatar should appear like you
did at the beginning see how you have
recon and soul with there so basically
if you just turn off your webcam but you
keep your mic on that's what should
happen there you go q can you talk yes
I'm just asking with the weird mask
again yes that's well I'm glad to have
you both over there gorgeous grammatic
was talking [ __ ] in your comments saying
you'll never come on rent a failures
gonna keep messing with us but you're
here yes awesome
yeah and knocks we're gonna be talking
about in this episode anime that really
inspired us motivated us changed our
life in some way does anyone want to
start
before I go on a massive rant about
Gurren Lagann guys really of course i'm
pretty sure we all know what i want to
be talking about today one piece the one
piece boy actually you're all wrong
[Music]
konnichi and Ichi the mice invited to
face an audience
hey Adam it's like changed your life
have a lot to do of like when you
watched it or what it's about like it's
definitely a personal thing for anyone
like how it resonated with you if you
guys don't mind me start and get scoffs
you can eat you the mighty disciple just
cuz the time in my life that I watched
it it was about like grade 9 in high
school
and if you guys don't already know the
people watching can teach in my disciple
is about a character known as Kenichi
Shira Hama who basically had like
nothing going for him he was who wasn't
that good at school was horrible of
martial arts wasn't good with girls like
much going for a man being grade 9 not
really knowing too many people I kind of
resonated with it I guess
and I wasn't almost never I was never
the most motivated person and the way
can eat she is my disciple as the bike
goes he ends up over the top masters and
he trained in martial arts but while
he's training in martial arts and
getting stronger and having these badass
fights he grows as an individual in
another area other areas and you really
see the transformation from the
beginning at the end like his confidence
his strength how he is around people
that his entire persona changes he gets
really well developed and I personally
really like I guess I found him very
motivating like in grade 9 I didn't do
any sports who didn't get involved super
confident cuz I'm a grade 9 right but
then I guess I found the motivation in
it I started working out the next year I
did like five or six sports I wasn't
very driven I feel like has inspired me
it'd probably be can each of the
microcycle I really plugged me up and
got me motivated to do something with my
life in a way that's awesome Ann and I
really like your new background it's
pretty cool we get some pollsters behind
us as well if you can see they're
Cowboys one yeah we got yours we got
some edgy ryuko
we got a key yo Cole Andrew your call
you know I'm saying it like what
actually what happens your flag where is
it it's still there I just don't feel
like setting it up because it's like I
prefer to be able to just take
and waving randomly on the street when
we shout out to some of the regulars in
Vienna my boy gorgeous we got Brandon
saying hi we got Nick victory fire Ethan
Saiga - yeah I'm Stuart Lee of course
forgotten on girl bro anime fanboy I
some Nana in there earlier really cool
beeps by the way gorgeous said oh yeah
ghost hunter and Ryan are there I'll go
stalker and gorgeous said that Code
Geass really taught him kind of the
horrors of war and how you know war
really is like losing a relative I
actually went to war as a child back in
the former Yugoslavia so I kind of had
that experience but definitely I feel
like anime is a really good you know
some anime really good enemy can make
you think of something that like I know
that grave of the fireflies the film is
probably the best anti-war film I've
ever seen because it really brings the
horrors of war and what this means to
light like this it really resonates with
you so yeah like I'm a big fan of Ghibli
films in general but that film it's not
like your positive film it's like I've
filmed it's just like war is terrible
and here's why and it's really powerful
Code Geass had a completely different
you know impression that it left on me
it was really it was the first anime I
watched that wasn't one of those you
know kids shown in type things and I
feel like it really drew me into being
tired you know realm of anime for sure I
think it was Daniels please his day as
my favorite how crazy is that nice man I
really like Cody s was probably the
second or third anime ever watched in
terms of them non shown in a you know
regular anime and also I loved the whole
military strategy aspect of politics
aspect it was like an adult anime it
really talks about the consequences you
know what it takes to be a leader how
sometimes the good guys in the bad guys
you can't really tell who's who because
both the good guys and the bad guys are
killing innocent people because they
believe they're doing the right thing
right so I think that's a really good
example Josh Daphnia what's up Taylor's
said in the
dad he said highschool DxD inspired him
to make a harem
I guess everyone in somewhere actually
posted a picture I made about a year ago
of my harem dream I'm pretty sure
everybody saw it on this score is like
me in the middle sitting on a chair like
a cool man and I had about ten girls my
favorite series just surrounding me
completely I actually put on this cord
again if you guys haven't seen it a lot
of it yes and by the way guys recon has
joined finally the anime up or discord
server and if you want to join its link
is in the description and Nagi is acted
there he's loving it he's loving it
because it's such a sick community I am
with his wife who's with his body
pillows you know he's we have so much
dirt on him now that we can use in the
future it's beautiful welcome recon
well since I'm talking I guess he kind
of like si oh yeah no it's not my
favorite shoe but it's one of my
favorite shows we don't need that much
more dirt are you trash talking about
Sao Paulo Keys no this is not the place
maybe next week
there's nothing gets triggered man
recently guess sometimes I just throw
shots in there just just for fun okay
who was your favorite anime then didn't
I say that already you said yeah code is
code gives yeah I haven't watched a
comment well reconsecrate god watches
like 87 anime every season like all the
seasonal ones yeah I watch all the news
ones yeah so it's hard for him to like
catch up on older stuff but I mean
that's really honest oh hey I like SEO a
lot more than your average youtuber yeah
I mean it's not it's it's overrated how
much it's hated like it's not a great
anime but it's by no means is like the
worst anime ever
there's cringing moments but there's
cringy moments in almost every anime
right
it's just that sao keeps being
emphasized as kind of like it Held's up
to a standard of horribleness i mean it
is bad but like it's not like I can't I
watched the whole thing
have to stop watching how bad it was and
there's a plenty of anime that other
people like like Tokyo Gould that I had
to stop watching because like I know the
manga is better but the enemy I was just
like man all right well couldn't do it
my next video should hopefully be fifty
sarcastic facts on Sao actually on you
peace oh yes good stuff yes then will
not get triggered and I do not get laugh
and don't laugh challenge and it's
targeted at the critics and the fans so
a little heat for everyone and I react
to it that's a great idea
I'll definitely react that video you've
got to get so many dislikes knocks but
I'm looking forward to it it's gonna be
showed me how people don't understand
the word sarcasm so oh no oh no no there
is no such thing as sarcasm or jokes on
the Internet
in terms on YouTube I have so many times
had you know people commenting stuff
where it's like I was obviously joking
and they're like you idiot how could you
say this and I was like oh and
especially Google Docs because your
channel is a lot of like satire oh man
satire is lost on people often on
YouTube and one of your videos got about
out of 200 dislikes because of that one
reaction you made about Aaron you like
transform reaction videos are the worst
but we were when we were June lycra live
reactions to the target line season to
one episode I was anxious for Aaron to
transform and fight Rider so I was like
come on Aaron transform man what are you
waiting for
just kind of in the heat of the moment
and I got all this hate from people
saying you [ __ ] it's because he is
emotionally tortured
how could you okay you be such an
[ __ ] like dude like it's an
on-the-spot reaction like I just get
some of the reacting that same way you
would doesn't mean that you corny you
know in the moment we will never be a
reaction channels good luck with that
recon no I'm doing fine man I'm actually
getting a lot of the people and then to
my community which is great cuz of your
top ten video yes I'm still happy about
it well um I have to I have to shout out
your top ten videos even though you
included Eromanga sensei on the latest
one I
because you have a good ear for good
music and what kind of music goes with
white and you really do a good job
editing those videos man and like a lot
of the songs you pick I'm like man I
gotta find that song and then like
listen to later so yeah good job
yep well I guess I can state my favorite
my anime that really inspired me and I'm
pretty sure you guys should know what it
is take a good guess online
no it's boku no pico oh no joking
anyways the anime that inspired me is
Claude it has inspired me to start my
own family and then so I can love them
to the fullest of the rest of my life
because the main character who fell in
love with Nagisa and he had a little
cute daughter named ushio it has really
inspired me because the story hit me it
touched me so hard because he has lost
his family he has lost his wife he has
lost his little child and so he was you
know in his life he it was so hard for
him so this is what is this is what this
story has inspired me to actually start
my own family and hopefully will look
them to the fullest
those men that's a hugely important
anime to me to fanatical and after story
in particular by the way Josh Daphne
laws Natsu sir edge Lord shot those ANBU
Jack killer red look at all these people
in here old familiar faces welcomed by
sukoshi Coulson what's up guys
imperialist opinions I could go all day
and yeah I come at I love clan after
story one of my favorite anime and the
ending is probably my favorite ending in
the history of anime as I soul knows he
keeps bugging me to make that video
where I explain that ending and I want
to do that but I've been just so busy
with other stuff right but I definitely
love that I love how that anime teaches
you to kind of like think outside the
box in terms of what ends up happening
having you know how people's wishes and
positive energy can actually change the
world that is the kind of symbolism I
feel in much of
sorry and of course there's a lot about
relationships learning about
relationships in after story they go
beyond high school and actually are in
an adult relationship they have a kid
right so a lot of stuff that way and I
know goals and clematis his favorite
anime of all time my brother so he loves
it I it's also one of my top ten for
sure so yeah absolutely great example
there a recon pretty sure mmm hey by the
way guys
last week we did beat our like record
for the previous week I think we're
never like 103 legs so let's see if we
can beat that record this week drop up
like if you like rant cafe and you're
enjoying these videos and hopefully we
can beat that by the end of next week
we're gonna be beating the record we
sell last week on the way and they do
just just commented in anime that is so
well worth talking about go enokitake oh
but welcome to the enemy dude uh it's so
life-changing as well he also fed [ __ ]
box I don't really want to talk about it
because it might be spoilers to the
people who didn't watch it well you
should definitely read the manga the
manga ends differently Oh does it yeah
the man who goes slightly more like
beyond that point cuz that point that's
still high school uh with the manga
there then they've kind of like
graduated and then they're talking about
like University and stuff so ah and
there's a bit more content in the middle
and stuff like the old male school
friends and stuff know the ones that you
ain't talking to you actually see them
and stuff on you and you more see the
yatra CDs the sister the ears the older
sister yes yes we see her in the Makah
and you see more of her husband the
brazilian so yeah I actually couldn't
get a hold of coke Itachi I looked high
and low weight not home it's on gogo
animates on nine anime yeah sounds like
you wanted actually purchase it oh
really oh there you go then
like a month ago still new hmm finally a
rising star in the chat says Hajime no
Ippo inspired him to get ripped but he
still working example of an
inspirational me another one goes and
loves he he was inspired to start
jogging again after watching that anime
he loves it Heidi bow is fantastic it's
mostly to overcome your fear of bullying
that's what it teaches you beginning I'd
say yeah because he was bullied so
that's why he joined to do boxing to
overcome his fear of that so yeah and so
evil bro I definitely recommend Kenichi
and if you like and eg I recommend
Hajime no Ippo I feel like they could
improve had the same effect on me when I
like secondly she inspired me yeah watch
Niki yeah and we had in the chat second
Jack was asking about one punch man
season 2 we know it's happening it's in
development we just don't know release
it yet but I will little beyond on it
here on the channel and we're gonna let
you know as soon as there is a release
date also lanky was asking is anyone
here I'm a fan of attack on Titan and
yes absolutely
fans here I think I think everyone here
is a fan of attack on Titan leave yeah
we we love it we love it except you know
people knocks this channel think he's
not apparently because he makes funny
but not but no great stuff man I watched
a video left very hard you're sarcastic
you're sarcastic facts about the talking
thing and your sarcastic trailer was
well thank you very much yeah awesome
story and I don't know I don't know if
you know this but I featured the latest
that are in the video on my weekly news
video where I recommend people to go
check stuff out really yeah I thought
about it I did feature you in there
because I really enjoyed it
but yeah I'm actually working right now
on an attack on Titan video a theory
video a theory video guys about the true
origins of the Titans that I'm really
excited about I've been doing all this
research and like more stuff is just
clicking into place so I'm almost done
the script I'm gonna be hopefully
recording that tonight and then coming
out with
in the next few days and I'm psyched
because I'm gonna be explaining why I
think that we see dinosaurs in the
season 2 opening of attack on Titan oh
well I've been getting these questions a
lot I think like y-you know can you
involve the season-opening why do we see
all these animals dinosaurs and I was
like I would love to but I want to have
an actual good theory I don't want to
just kind of BS it and now the more I
thought about it there's a great theory
I think that it's great that I have so I
can't wait to you know get that done and
see what everyone thinks about it
obviously it's just a theory we can't
know for sure but I'm really excited for
it so I hope hope people like it that's
awesome that's really good you've been
working really hard you're almost not
just me for sure like the two US two
brothers we run the channel and we both
have been working hard that's why we've
been putting out so many videos if it
was just me or just saying there's no
way we could have done it you're at the
line of 40,000 like so close yeah which
is amazing we're almost at 40,000
subscribers which is so crazy especially
since we were so celebrating 20,000 like
five weeks ago which is not so yeah
thanks everybody for your support being
here right not really we're watching
this afterwards thanks guys really means
a lot
and of course means a lot to have the
support of my friends here in with me
Knox recon soul and brave I'm not really
your friend
if you trash talk about sa young I mean
I will I guess we're not friends because
I'm sorry bro no I actually watched
Italy two or three times I don't know
how I can call it trash by the way Anna
Mataji are you watching fate apocryphal
yes but I haven't watched the third
episode yet did you fall for the trap no
how do you read the light novel no
because now I see every time I see a
lolly I assume it's a trap immediately I
just assume unless proven otherwise
so I I assumed Jack the Ripper was a
trap too and people like no it's not a
try but I'm like I don't know
okay fine back on topic back on topic I
think one year and made that I watch
that really got me thinking about things
like in life in general was serial
experiments lain yeah well with that
with that it was like this girl and
basically there's this think of it like
like an online network and it kind of
called wired right and then the way that
the way they're shown in stuff you get
to see the character but like as her
personas that she's showing people there
are online and stuff so you you'll see a
like one moment like maybe like will
smiling the happy in their next moment
you might see her like a like an edge
Lord or something in another moment
crying about something you know and it
will get you thinking about like
personas that we put out of ourselves
and like what we can get away with on
online and stuff cuz life is whatever
anonymous yeah it means you could just
paint yourself up to be whatever the
hell you like you know and things like
that and yeah it just got me thinking
about things like that and how important
it is like just to be like treat
yourself in general you know because
then at one point she she then ends up
having to kind of erase her personas
because they end up with coming to kind
of counterproductive and stuff she can't
manage them all so then she ends up
getting to the point where she needs to
like erase them all and kind of like
reset yeah I mean which you know is it
was very thought-provoking for me yeah I
mean thinking about you know the
fakeness that you know people put out
and things like that and you know don't
want to keep that don't lie and say you
know they could be keyboard warriors and
you know just cat whatever crap they
want to chat you know and yeah it was
just yeah just really good a point and
another interesting one in terms of that
was I thought the film summer Wars kind
of in terms of that I don't know yeah
yeah yeah
also first season of Psychopaths
especially that first
mark has a similar kind of message as
well very much influenced I'm sure by
serial experiments lain because like
there's the whole arc the first arc in
psychopath season one is where someone
who had who is known as an internet
persona is killed in real life and a
bunch of them are being killed so yeah I
thought that was really cool I kind of
like have these internet personas
especially not futuristic world how much
of persona is real how much is fake so
yeah that's a really good example some
other anime kind of like cyberpunk anime
that got me thinking about society and
where the future is heading and all that
type of stuff
includes psychopath host Oh ergo proxy
Neon Genesis Evangelion all of those
really got me thinking about like
philosophical aspects of where humanity
is heading so I really want those essays
that there are two main reasons
particularly for anime in general what
does anime in general actually inspired
to inspire you people to do so it
inspires me when I watch an anime series
it inspires me to watch more anime and
the second thing is that inspires me to
actually want to visit Japan and you
know explore explore the world of Japan
go to anime land and just the culture in
general that's what anime overall
inspires me to do you mean Kiba Hara yes
Tokyo Aki Baro was that Disneyland yeah
and of course just to clarify it's
Akihabara speaking of speaking of you
clearly have there are around there
however you pronounce that
properly NOx are you here I am here I
want to say that I don't trust you man
because you just say you from Quebec but
you don't have a French accent and that
is very suspicious to me no answer there
my parents are English speakers
ah I see but you do speak French do teep
it okay yeah cuz I iLike French I can
communicate in French I want to perfect
it
but I only like the polizia French I
can't even understand much of like
chemical are French so um I guess I'm a
French snob you could say French sucks
I took nine years of French and the cats
like speak a word I'm buried if I did
not like the language well in Canadian
schools they force you to take French
whether you like it or not and that's
why a lot of people just start hating it
because they're being forced to take it
rather than you know encouraged to or
something so they get like a blowback
reaction which I think kind of sucks
because French is a cool language I like
it and I and along with Spanish and a
lot of other languages I think are cool
and I want to learn but who else wants
to go with an anime that inspired them
before I and get into something or or is
it my turn because all you guys
mentioned something well there's another
one dimension which is zankyou no terror
which is that that one that one was
really interesting you know looking at
how governments operate and stuff and
how much they really think of their
citizens you know especially when you
look at like things that are going on in
the world like now and then you know you
see that and how how far the
government's prepared to go to keep a
lid on certain things yeah I mean it
really yeah it really gets you thinking
yeah but yeah especially since I study
politics and kind of like you know
statecraft as you would say I've studied
it for many years I'm really interested
in anime like terror in residence which
you know kind of explored a whole what
is the government really up to what are
you know what's going on behind the
scenes and stuff like that so yeah good
example and of course for me like I mean
there are a lot of anime that really
inspired me that kind of changed my life
in many ways
and there's anime that when you're like
a kid that inspire you like you know
Pokemon and stuff inspire you to all be
adventurous and you know overcome
challenges the basic stuff and then
obviously as you grow
you look at more mature anime than
inspire you for different things someone
mentioned the chat might have been on
Google I'm not sure by the way also
shout out to Luca Luna and everybody
else in the chat
I think Ambu said fooly cooly and/or
FLCL and I loved that I made a whole
video on how much I love it because of
the whole concept that I feel that it's
trying to teach us is that the adult
world makes no sense
you know the expectations of the adult
world the the social kind of structures
and things expect you to conform so you
know get a certain kind of job dress in
a certain kind of way do certain kinds
of things all this stuff doesn't
actually make sense if you look at it
and like like I said it references and
reminds me of the little prince which
also exposes the adult world for making
in many cases less sense than the world
of non adults because kids are often
more in it your and more and have more
comment in this box or like social
expectations and stuff a little prince
is huge for that it's referenced by
fully coolly of course my favorite
philosopher jean-jacques Rousseau for
who so talks about this stuff and how
man by nature is one way pure but then
by society he becomes corrupted because
there's all these things and now he has
to you know compete with others and look
better than others and this creates all
these chains that keep him down
so I loved fully coolly because of that
and I know a lot of people like this
doesn't make sense
but like I did a whole analysis of it
and I think the more you look at it the
more sense it actually makes which I
love well you mentioned do rap before
and I find that that inspired me in many
ways actually because it's about a city
more than it's about any individual and
it's about all the happenings in the
city and how everyone individually is
insignificant but everything they do
builds into the entire universe and
builds up the city as to what it is yeah
it's interesting because I've seen that
in books before and where the city is
actually the main character rather than
a person but I think that's a really
unique concept that I like it my one
thing would do not
is that I thought that the pacing was
off it was too slow because they had so
many characters and a lot of them are
really cool and interesting but like I
wanted some explored more and they
wouldn't because they kept going to
different ones and then for like that
you had the same problems me like Game
of Thrones where sometimes they'll go to
like a Brandon Stark and I'm like I
don't care about Brandon Stark
I want to see what Jon Snow is doing I
want to see what the Narus is doing
right so that it had that issue for me
but overall I thought it was enjoyable
but wait dude call me pan says what was
his favorite phosphor again jean-jacques
whose soul okay well that French is
working for you I did like I did like
what was a deaf parade
I thought that was really like
intriguing in you know just like just
looking at from the cultural point of
view of the creator's honor of how they
how they was measuring death and right
and wrong in in people's actions and
stuff and how they would judge them I
mean especially when it came to them the
the woman who's like a mother of like
four or five and she got like killed by
her assistant but then there's the young
guy who basically in protest to his
parents splitting up and his dad me
Marion he just became was a hick on
Maury and he was just staying in his
room all the time and they eventually
like he just taught himself by phoning
himself at the window like automatically
with that like the Western Christian
culture you would see it as a suicide
automatically that dust like yeah you're
going to help yeah I mean that's you
don't get no come back from that but
then to see him get saved and the mother
not was just yeah I mean for me
personally it felt so wrong yeah I mean
it was just like no come on no this is
ridiculous no but you know it's also i
opening to see what they value more yeah
i mean rather than just the way they
died
it was more what the what the person was
actually feeling like internally and
they're like they drive behind their
actions yeah so then how they died you
know so yeah that's a real interesting
points all because anime does teach us a
lot about a culture completely different
from ours because if you're from the
West and you look at like anime
especially anime that are you know
dealing with Japanese culture like
mushishi yeah yeah I think that it
really opens up your horizons and you
know broadens what you come to expect
from things because cultural cultures
are very different and values are very
different expectations are very
different and it really does make you
kind of consider these things by the way
shout out to mega it came mega anime
opening to a soft bro he's on this court
active as well and guys if you want to
join our discord link is in the
description we're active all the time
having cool things going on be sure to
check that out what was what was I gonna
say now that's the question what was I
gonna say
so all were saying we're talking about
the pros yes mushishi again I really
like that show because a lot of people
say they're boring to them but like I
loved it because it was almost like a
meditative experience to watch it like
do the portrayals of nature and you know
how nature works in harmony and you need
a balance so gingko he goes and where
there's too much mushi too many of them
in one place they're causing the certain
disrupt ences so there's in order to
restore the balance right like the whole
concept of yin and yang is very heavy
there and I loved also how in many ways
the animation is realistic it's not like
overdramatic like the characters other
than ginkgo who is white hair because of
a specific reason all the characters
look pretty plain they look like you
know your plain villagers from Japan and
like 1800's or something
they're you know they're not you know
have crazy hair colors they're not made
especially attractive no big huge eyes
but yet it the nature is portrayed in
such a beautiful way it's not like
you're you know no game no life like
crazy colors its natural colors and you
so beautiful so I love that artistic
aspect of mushishi as well
I think sports anime like haikyuu
probably inspired me and you know I love
haikyuu it made me love volleyball as a
sport a lot more from watching haikyuu
and it taught me how to improve as a
human theme because he natal first of
all when like in season one the Heike
when he started he wasn't that great at
all but as a series kept on progressing
he kept working hard he kept on striving
to become the best he kept on improving
his skills and that is what inspired me
to become a better human being and to
you know be a better person
thank you inspired me to watch more
sports anime of course I was really
attached to my muscle but ki joke or
directors I think doing spines you
inspires you to like more people my
question fine booty man boys that
exactly it's wrestling girls wrestling
no it's it's love nice yeah that's my
urea nice try there
I will now watch your knife sorry Luna
but I will watch Kaede ro I hope I hope
I wish they would make more seasons they
probably won't but unfortunately Omar
asks about full man documents
Brotherhood or attack on Titan and yes
these are both amazing anime Fullmetal
Alchemist Brotherhood I love it's one of
my very own enemies of all time it also
teaches you about balance about you know
play you know going too far playing God
in the beginning with what human
transmutation what Edward Alphonse do it
also there's a lot of messages there I
feel about the clash between Western and
Eastern civilizations because if you
look on mysteries the country where they
are the western country and especially
the homunculi I think
represent capitalist society and
consumerism and it goes to the point
where they're literally consuming people
and sacrificing people in order to
become more powerful and the whole
country becomes a sacrificial altar they
want to consume the souls of these
people to create wealth for themselves
and power whereas from the Eastern
perspective friendship and community are
the values that Edward and our
protagonists have that allow them to
defeat the bad guys so I feel it's
definitely in that enemy I love the
clash between on the one hand community
friendship and on the other hand
consumerism greed quest for power so
that's a great one attack on titan is so
powerful because of what the world it
creates like it's such a hard world to
deal with it's so brutal but it in such
a setting you learn a lot about humanity
the nature of mankind what would you do
if you were in descending if you didn't
know if you're gonna live or die it
teaches us a lot about war about
suffering about the v of there are two
sides to every story especially if
you've caught up to the manga you know
that there's a side to the story of
Reiner and Annie and bertolt that is
that humanizes them and kind of explains
where they're coming from so again it's
not so clear-cut who are the bad guys
who are the good guys and that is I
think the strongest anime are able to do
just that so yeah alt and full Monaco's
brotherhood both amazing amazing anime
full motherhood touch racism a lot i
think there was the whole idea of the
issue islands getting exterminated and
scar out for revenge causing more fights
and Wars and there were the homunculus
of-- humans as lesser creatures as well
yeah yeah for sure yeah I think about a
lot of animated unfurling on like some
you know some people being stuck you and
of course attack on Titan perfect
example with the LD ins and how they're
treated and I like again manga but LD
ins
and I mean now it might make like an
sees with the juice like the way how
Molly is
yeah you don't have like the stars on
them and stuff exactly it's exactly I
don't want to get too much into it
because I know recon and knock seven
read the manga plebs yeah I'm gonna
leave it at this I think hajimeta no
girl has inspired me body pillow of
yummy charm I really want a body pillow
over so badly I don't know I think the
only thing that enemy has taught me is
that girls start wearing belts instead
of skirts it would be as effective I
agree
listen I'm not I'm gonna admit I I have
watched the first episode of [ __ ] Matt
the nogal and it was funny so I'm
definitely gonna keep watching it good
girl with girl with green eyes and dark
skin is best girl right there I'm
telling that I'm telling you that right
now the main girl no her friend her
friend oh oh the other way yeah like
like you wanna go to karaoke and she's
like no dad that's my girl right that
what I think it's Franco yes yes so yeah
definitely you remember her name Josh by
the way said that he thinks that kisses
and monster Musume changed his life so
but recon yeah like chain of events I
receive access the bestiality has me I
think as original girl taught us a lot
of things because the main character
doesn't he doesn't have a girlfriend so
it taught us the weight overweight it
taught us the proper way of how to get a
girl easy to get down on your knees just
begun please don't be or understanding
of how to pick up women from anime I'm
not an edgy anime please don't do it
please
and we love arrests this light look not
even not even not even arrest but the
girl will laugh and you're like don't do
it men you got a a girl watch I had a
convention a strong man who respects
himself not not not what happened there
yeah
anima did you watch sent or just like
Jojo said because he washed Kaka gooey I
will watch it I haven't watched it yet I
was thinking of maybe organizing on this
score like a live watching where we can
watch together bring go to okay so we
just gotta find the time that works but
I would love to cuz we can on this chord
you can actually like set it up so that
you're streaming together and chatting
while you're watching so I would love to
do that and like watch that and kind of
with Jojo there and you there and then
we kind of kind of like talk about and
I'll be fun cool gorgeous Grimek just
brought up an anime that I think is well
worth inspiration schooldays what is
with you no no no it doesn't inspire you
it teaches you don't be a dick not to
cheat on your girlfriends otherwise you
are dead yeah but that's the thing
teaching is important to and someone
brought up assassination classroom in
the chat and yeah that show it's just
outrageous it's like to me that show is
such an example what anime is like
completely crazy plot like an octopus
monster teaching a class everyone's
trying to kill them like that's the
whole fun like that's you know gonna see
that anywhere but in an anime however
there is a lot of like deep lessons
there about teaching students and about
you know the importance of education and
how it should be approached I really
think that there is definitely some
really cool messages between that show
in general the show is just for fun and
some blast to watch it's funny but I
think there are some really cool lessons
there as well so yeah I'm a big fan of
that show that's what makes it so great
so it's all just life lessons no get
through it and the ending I just watch
oh yeah ending yeah for sure I could
just watch the second season like last
week when uh adamak reminded me of it
Cowboy Bebop has been brought up Bryan's
brought up and a few other people
haven't brought it up to I don't know if
comedy up would change my life
however I loved the characters the
interplay between the characters like
Faye and you know Edie and Spike and
Jett like I love the cast I love how
they work together
I love the anime as a whole the watching
of it
so yeah I don't know it wasn't I don't
know if it inspired me to you know do
great things but it definitely I
definitely loved it and enjoyed it and
would love to see more of these
characters in any way possible I would
love for it to be some kind of sequel
because I just like I love them so much
so much can I talk about Cohn Okazaki or
no yeah yeah go ahead
I'll give you much away please all right
first of all it's about the the main
character Ishida I think that's his name
is a crew and everything was the main
character named Ichi now believe right
yeah I think so yeah yeah
okay so it inspired me that not to be a
bully basically because he was bullying
a girl who was deaf and it just occurred
every time like the bullying he caused
even more and more trouble to her and
there was a lot of problems but then
when he grew up and he became older he
decided you know what I'm gonna stop
bullying because people when he bullied
this girl people then started to hate
him as well people started to bully him
as well because he bullied poor innocent
girl and when he grew when he became
older he started to realize okay I need
to stop this and to become a better
person that's what the enemy teaches you
overall to become a better person not to
bully her girls not to do anything
stupid
so yeah yeah I mean there's another
aspect I got from it as well which is
everyone has their own issue because
like Lucas has issues everyone has their
own issue it's pretty much like that in
life everyone has their own issue and
everyone has their own like cross to
bear or something to overcome or get
over complex maybe or whatever you know
and you don't always understand it
like straightaway or you might not
notice it straight away and sometimes
when you do something you could offend
or you know trigger without realizing
Kono's wonderful deep series there I
couldn't get past the second episode it
was you just wasn't cosmos surrounded by
total idiots and their close friends and
even though everyone is completely
insane in their own way it developed a
bond somehow and everyone in life has
idiosyncrasies as well and it was also
funny as hell it was fantastic I guess
it wouldn't be a stream if I didn't talk
about one piece like Briggs by the way
while you talk I could try to think
about it really all you talk I have to
go through washroom don't take that as
me not caring about one piece or
anything yeah but go ahead go ahead I'll
be back guys also hi
ironic meteor he said hey what's up yeah
I've been trying to I wouldn't be a
stupid talk about one for you so I'm
trying to think about like how it could
have inspired me or like changed my life
it is one of my favorite anime of all
time and got me into the medium of anime
by then the one thing one piece that's
like wish is to chase your dreams like
the entire show is about either Luffy
chasing his dream
Zoro chasing like the entire crew has
their own inspiration and that brought
them together and this pretty much of
something up is to like fight for your
dream then fight for what you believe in
and like they all have their own dream
they want to accomplish even if it's so
unrealistic they still push for it
that's about it the unlikely friendship
that's sprouted in one piece yeah I
don't one has their own crazy sad
backstories in different ways and they
all ended up in the same spot at the
same time you know I feel like I can
connect to any anime fan just cuz he's
an anime fan no matter what he is or
what he does
no no SF SAO fan so I love the fact ever
maybe an American
stop stop with all this nonsense I don't
want to hear it I just don't have to
[ __ ] hear it boys
it's what I heard you ask and be
enlightened I will I won't watch it I
will watch it when I get the time but at
the moment there's just the animal this
seasonal anime that new anime just call
me around because YouTube channel all
throughout watching seasonal anime and
reacting to it I understand
I don't want to kill myself I had to
watch every show like well take a little
bit I'd say that sword art online
actually the romance aspect of sword art
online got me into the romance genre a
lot more because I watched it five years
ago now and since then I've become much
more into anime up till that point that
was more of the fantasy action guy yeah
I'd say the romance was good at first
like up to like when he woke up that was
great after that things just changed
like the whole cousin sister thing that
the fact he actually like said to her
that all basically I need to get Asuma
back first before I can then like give
you your answer that that is like
[ __ ] because that then is saying
that he's got a chance yeah I mean like
as soon as not that good for him like he
would actually consider leaving us
sooner for someone else
yeah and for me that just that wound
yeah yeah that's the only aspect that
was holding the show together for me
that was the only aspect so when that
fell through the whole thing thoughtful
sauger time on one piece by the way
goals that are really getting into one
piece he's God let me show you let me
show you guys can goes and really watch
check it out it's the box set for the
manga which is drooling while I'm so
proud to make a phone call I was turning
off my mic and saying because someone's
trying to contact me but I heard one
piece I turned it back on I'll be right
back in like two minutes yet okay
regards to everyone from Eagle burger by
the way he's always sing for me in my
next thingy Oh is he here
he's in the chart no he is not he just
messaged me at this chord okay I don't
know I know my countless goals and have
enough time to watch 700 episodes in one
piece
well he hasn't yet he's in the process
oh he's in the process he knows what's
good no I'm gonna take him about a year
to actually complete the entire thing
well he wants to do it and that's cool
with me and he 1,000% worth it okay my
most legendary anime marathon was I was
in a van driving from Montreal to New
York and I had eight hours to sit and
watch one piece so I was a bit slow so I
had to put it out like four times speed
and fly 350 episodes
Wow guys 50 episodes at four times speed
totally worth the headache
wait wait wait wait did you have that in
subs or dubs
so how the hell did you eat that like
four times feet well he's clearly he's
clearly mad man
knocks Taku which is why he is on rent
cafe guys no one here is a sane person
Grand Cafe is YouTube Kona Suba did it
it truly is it truly is by the way
someone mentioned Trigon in comments
earlier I also like Trigon my one issue
with Trigon is that Vash the Stampede
doesn't want to kill to the point of
like ridiculousness kind of like you're
Goku style he doesn't want to kill at
all cost
even though I might actually save a lot
of lives so that was an issue for me but
overall I really enjoyed it the
Steampunk Western feel the themes
explored it was really cool definitely a
highly recommended anime and that goals
and saw isn't finished which I always
bother him about Luca said something
funny
where was this yeah he says he says
something about Tokyo ghoul it's like I
was inspired by the fact that
an anime with such a bad premise can be
so successful talking about Tokyo ghoul
so you can truly achieve anything if
they could achieve popularity from a
shitty show yeah I didn't like the anime
of Tokyo ghoul
I like the manga the first half of the
manga but the anime was just it was bad
it was done bad like when it first came
out it was really heavily censored so
that like I mean most of it is go so for
it to be heavily censored as it was just
kind of ruined there anyway the second
season then totally went off track and
was just really overall weird and yeah
yeah just yeah that may didn't do it
justice at all yeah the problem with
Tokyo ghoul it's just gore the sake of
gore its edginess for the sake of
edginess with like attack on Titan all
the violence and gore makes sense
because you know exactly you know it all
is driven by the plot with Tokyo ghoul
is just like no it's like what bubble
edgy teens on tumblr love let's make a
show about that and you know I'll even
say in the first part of Tokyo ghoul
there weren't really a plot per se just
basically he's being like infected he's
become like half gone now like he's in
this world that's it you know he never
had any like specific goal to to do or
be someone or you know I mean those just
it was just he's in this world now and
it's just dangers coming his way
thank you off the danger you know and
that's it that was the plot just dangers
coming that's it
well I mean the plot was horrible like
100% I would like or the second season
Elise the first season wasn't as bad
there was there was no second but what's
it called I wouldn't say it was gore for
the sake of gore like they're just like
that were in the fight yes cannibals in
it so they have care like I wouldn't say
it was still plot driven even if the
plot was bad music and they inspired me
as well I mean they have such an
interesting story
specifically for romance let's take for
example like your line April or Foucault
making noise anonymous noise those two
series have inspired me a lot they think
what there's those two music kind of
made that were better but I'll talk
about that after but you say you say
okay oh those are my favorite music Adam
a [ __ ] monkey noise and your light
April they caused me to love the music
genre even more because of the romance
that's behind the story overall and it
is it could inspire a lot of people to
actually start you know their own music
band maybe start learning how to play an
instrument like guitar or piano or
whatever this is what music anime has
really caused the enemy community to you
know to do a lot of inspiration when the
music genre so what so the two for me
was a kids on the slope or sucking
Michio pollen now kids good really good
yeah this would I really like that and
Nodame cantabile
no it's not I'm a can't abuse all oh can
table a table there we go well yeah
those two were really good like to agree
with both of those and another one
that's it's like a left-field one but
that I really found it was samurai
champloo with the hip hop music yeah
like they're there in Edo period Japan's
samurai but they like the whole thing is
themed with hip hop music modern hip hop
music which I thought was really
interesting
yeah by me I would have put out a music
and oh yeah right music in anime but
yeah I don't know if you guys saw that
it's a heavy romance one two girls don't
look the same roommates one of them's in
a band
it's called Nana yeah funny enough air
yes I don't think I shot at him out yeah
but he's in the Chad be inactive thanks
bro
and of course if you like right if they
don't forget to like drop like we're
trying to read beat the record of last
rank of it which is like a hundred and
four likes or something so drop that
like and of course if you like chatting
on a daily basis join the discord server
link in the description we're gonna go
chill there afterwards and of course I'm
gonna be working then on the attack on
Titan script and I'm hyped for another
thing I wanted thrown in here guys is
the Ghibli films and Miyazaki in general
what I love about his films is that he
really has a kind of like positive
beautiful positive view of life and how
you know people of heap of human beings
of life of nature and he does such a
great job of portraying these in his
anime and like for example my neighbor
totoro I watched that anime like twice a
year at least and the reason I have to
re-watch is because I just find it's
such like a beautiful experience
rewatching and it's like it's like a
meditation just to watch it to remind
myself of how awesome it is because it
has such a positive outlook on life you
know you see I mean over there like
there in a village where it's like
backwards then on technology it's like
you know you could modern people would
complain a lot about that stuff and yet
they love it they're having a great time
their mom is sick in the hospital and
yet they still you know it's still such
a positive view of nature of the balance
between humans living and nature and you
know the spirit of the mountain so a lot
of Japanese cultural things in there
it's just beautiful I love it so much
it's just amazing so I I'm a huge fan of
Ghibli and and Miyazaki for that yeah I
mean my favorite Ghibli movie I think is
when mommy was there that that I mean
that still can move meat it is alright
right now if I if I watched it right now
it would still move me that is is it's
just really moving but like how you say
like with the kind of happy Phil even
though like there's like bad things
going on yeah I would say the wind rises
yeah like that where his wife his wife
get sickly and stuff like that but she
keeps on telling like keep keep going
for you dreamed
keep designing the plane and stuff yeah
I mean not yet that was that was that
was good that was like yeah like
Miyazaki films they have such a charm to
them like they have that charm where
it's like they show you to love the
characters they to love life just like a
positive model of the life so many
things show like a negative out like
outlook life like Game of Thrones as
interesting as this I hate the pessimism
of it the cynicism
same thing with like Stephen King works
just take the cynicism about human
nature and about life compared to like
Ghibli films is completely completely
different yeah I mean I never wonder is
both artistic in the way is a shanti and
both really for provoking in the story
that is telling is the tale of Princess
Kaguya now for some reason it got right
it never never never did well for some
reason like when it came out I don't
know why but it is really it's really
interesting it's really interesting
because basically it's like this couple
is blessed with this child out of bamboo
of a bamboo plant or something and it's
like it's a gift from God starts off
tiny yeah I mean within a day the child
is like the size of a baby
yeah me and they were old couple you
know there must be easily lights semies
easily you know and then they're like
okay we're gonna have to find a wet
nurse for the baby and things like that
and then instantly the woman produces
breast milk yeah man she's able to feed
the baby so it's a proper gift from God
for them to have this child you know
child keeps on rapidly growing to like a
steady like teenage and the whole time
the child's just having fun cuz like
their country folk in it and the child's
having fun in the fields playing with
the other kids and things like this and
then the dad then has all feels the need
you know because of society's rules oh
we need to become like more upper-class
know it that's the only way that she's
gonna have a good life you know this is
a gift from God to have this child so
I'm gonna do my all coming
sure she's high society so now if they
like they move out of the the
countryside they're more like in the
city now which is nothing to be prim
improper she can't run about and play
anymore just to stay quiet all the time
and walk like a lady do calligraphy and
things like that and over time it just
ruins her life she feel so
claustrophobic she feels so like just
tied in and surrounded by people who
genuinely don't care about her they just
care about the status and then at one
point she just she's just had enough
it's supposed to be her party and no one
actually cares about her she just wants
out and she's like just throws away all
her clothes and she just once and she
goes like back in it because she wants
to go back to the fields where she was
where she was best where like life was
good for yeah yeah a week yeah for
provokin that's the brilliance of
miyazaki in general is he in his films
the themes are so much you know talking
about the simple life being noble and
the you should be humble and happy in
everyday life right you should be happy
in the simple things instead of trying
to constantly please someone or reach
some social expectation or some great
goal you know be happy in the everyday
be happy every single day with the
simple things you know with your family
with your friends and that is such an
important important message that in the
modern world is lost on so so many
people and it's like yeah it's like
that's why I keep rewatching films like
that because even though I've seen the
many times before it's like I want I
need to remind myself to ground myself
and think about you know enjoy the
little things enjoy every single day
don't strive for these you know social
expectations and you know competing with
others that's not happiness there's no
end to that you know no matter how
successful you are you you could be
always dissatisfied because you always
want more more and more
yeah there could always be some who's
higher status than you or someone who's
got more than you or got something
different to you so then straight away
you know you're in competition you want
to
chief that thing also so yeah it becomes
just an endless struggle
how about Charlotte I thought it was
executed terribly especially Indiana
don't sleep [ __ ] you what some of this
agrees Greek on I really like the first
episode it had me you know in trapped in
its world and stuff all right first of
all has no one watched Charlotte
I have not know it looks like a
super-powered kind of thing going on by
the way Josh Daphne said that clockwork
planet has a deep and psychological
message about clocks and sucking up
fingers yeah clockwork planet is like
like hand shakers like that [ __ ] has no
message it's ridiculous
ridiculous okay does anyone else wanna
say anything before I go into my Gurren
Lagann rant and close it out for the
evening I was it's your time all right
the reason why I think we're in log on
is the best anime of all time
is that it it just inspires you to think
outside the box to literally do the
impossible and now of course we know
that you know in real life you can't do
what they do they're powered by spiral
power things like that but spiral power
they're in that show represents the
human spirit you know the human drive to
keep doing great things and and being
better and doing the impossible and
that's so important the this concept of
do the impossible because as we
mentioned would fully Cooley and full
equally goes great with Gurren Lagann
CEMA creators of course in in the adult
world in the society that we have
there's a lot of social expectations you
have to do this you have to do that like
you mentioned soul with Princess Kaguya
you know it's not even about you anymore
as a person it's about what you can and
can't do you know well you can't do this
you can't do that you can't waste your
time on YouTube you know who could ever
make a career out of you too
we're talking about cartoons they like
as an adult you know that type of stuff
right and there's all these expectations
so you think yeah you have to conform
but thinking about this do the
impossible is like no you have to see
outside the box because often you don't
even know you're in the box
because of how conditioned you are to
believe these things and then the
metaphor of Plato's cave and of course
in Gurren Lagann the cave of the village
in the beginning it's like they don't
even know it that there is a ceiling
like there is an outside because they've
never seen it coming that knows because
of his father but they don't even think
they're like comedy or crease there is
nothing outside this village and same
thing in clay to escape the people in
the cave we're trapped in the cave they
don't know there's anything outside that
is how stuck there in the block there so
stuck in the box they don't even know
there is a box they don't even know
they're inside it and that is the
greatest slavery not understanding that
there is something beyond and so this
whole concept of doing the impossible it
teaches you to break through this box
called the possible and do the
impossible
think outside it when people tell you
can't do this it's not right you know
get a job as a lawyer because that's
that's a sure income and you're like no
I want to do something I love like I
don't know write books or be a youtuber
or whatever no you can't do the
impossible what others tell you're
impossible because it's not truly
impossible it's only impossible if you
believe it if they convince you then
it's impossible but if you believe it
and you're able to you know push through
those social pressures and expectations
you can do amazing things and that's why
I love Gurren Lagann fooly cooly and all
those type of shows because they truly
truly do inspire me in real life like I
truly strive to be like someone like
calming up who never shows fear never
shows you know never shows weakness and
is always striving like I know I'm never
gonna be like him exactly because he is
a larger-than-life character but just
because he's larger than life doesn't
mean that he's not an important
character because you look up to him
even if you never truly achieve his
greatness you will be better off as a
person by going you know looking up to
someone like that rather than someone
who's like you know know your place you
know still don't stick your head out too
far just go with the flow
kind of thing right so yeah rant over
for now
well powerful materialist opinions just
commented Animax changing our life our
life's right now bro now is like a
really good analysis and my kind of was
pretty inspiring your speech alone was
inspiring did thank you guys but that's
that's what it comes from anime right
anime media you think of this stuff and
that's all I eventually I will make a
whole video about who are along I'm
talking about all these things because
there's so much to talk about but yeah
like it really is looking into the
powers of many anime you know trying to
put math into the mix trying to see
exactly how powerful different attacks
are and in Gurren Lagann at the end when
they're just flying past galaxies how
fast would you say they're moving faster
than the speed of the possible yeah
they're moving gonna stay the fight that
you know fought over space and over time
yeah what all I find in like kind of
like I don't know two dimensions or
something like that well I I liked the
series more than the film's so you guys
are talk about the film's now no no no
disservice no series yeah cuz they were
in space weren't they but then on
everyone on earth could see them like a
projection of them fighting oh okay
which was really weird because obviously
if you're way in space you're in space
you wouldn't see some kind of weird
actually
you need to rewatch Gurren Lagann no I I
want to be watching I thought you were
talking about the whole cuz in the movie
they go there's a more thing but yeah
like they disrupt the space-time
continuum with the fight because of like
the anti spirals trying to control the
universe is stuff they create like the
whole disruption but again to me it's
just like it shows you it's a symbol the
anime is a symbol for don't be stuck by
what people you know travel why people
tell you is possible and impossible
don't think of it in terms of scientific
and physics and how much it makes sense
in our world think about how much it can
inspire us to be different and make
changes in our world even though our
laws of physics are different you know
we don't have spy
power that powers us but still that way
of thinking that is I think the
important thing the way of thinking
outside the box that is what the show
really teaches us herbal can be a hero
dozen of anime that kind of like I don't
know it has a feel of you know be nods
and you know inspiring you to you know
just keep going despite what people say
the is kind of out around about the same
time and that was a gay I don't know if
anyone saw that with the guys using the
roller blades and stuff so that that
kind of has that same kind of feel you
know so yeah of you know being awesome
rising up in a yeah yeah yes definitely
guys this was I think an amazing
discussion thank you all for your
contributions Knox thank you for being
here for the first time pleasure
pleasure
hopefully the first of many of course
you're always invited back just let me
know when you catch everyone in the chat
thank you so much for coming and
participating it's been a great time
drop a like if you enjoy rank a fail
let's see if we can beat that record and
yeah we're gonna join a discord server
if you want it's a lot of fun we have
special channels for like anime theories
anime news right we have a lot of events
that we organize we have a flag contest
coming up with your official item out
for a flag we have a writing contest
coming up with the best idea for an
anime and we're gonna be talking about
that on Rann cafe right here in one of
the episodes we're gonna have the best
ideas for a new anime we're gonna be
reading out here on Randolph and
deciding which one is our favorite so
that's something else we're doing we
have regular karaoke sessions and stuff
over there so be sure to check that out
I excited to work on this attack on
Titan theory about the dinosaurs tonight
hopefully finish it within the next few
days so look out for that before we go
I'm gonna just like hand it over to our
peeps here too so they can say who they
are and what they do on their channels
if they have a channel NOx you're new so
let's go to you hello I'm nuts
partial alcoholic I have a YouTube
channel and I get made fun of there
because I'm too sarcastic
and yes but he is hilarious I love his
sense of humor the guy's awesome be sure
to check him out link in the description
and we're gonna have him back here
because he's a great guy now to recon
I'll go last
oh god recon why you so complicated man
okay so you can be like I love you all
technically yes just move on to someone
else
Riggs are you here yes I am I want to uh
do you apologize for not being super
active this stream I've just been having
to do some stuff in between but thank
you so much for having me I am Briggs
from the YouTube channel all day anime I
make fact / like explanation videos
talking about concepts they're just cool
stuff about anime like my hero academia
or the seven deadly sins stuff like that
I wish I could do more one piece but
sadly it seems like my fan base does not
care for one piece content but I will be
implementing it every now and then what
do you say Knox trying to throw in a big
mom video no one seemed to like it I
like that I really liked it bro I like I
wish you could do more on one piece of
content well then for you it was worth
it hey if you learned anything from this
stream watch konnichi the miletti SSI
poll if you have already seen Kenichi
watch Hajime no Ippo or vice versa also
Gurren Lagann fantastic watch all very
inspirational and motivational Digimon
Digimon are the champions knowledge
failed uh to youth oh macha Wow okay
yeah hi everyone I'm so maka oh you guys
whom this code should know me and one
else wants to get to know me you can
find me on the discord I'm always there
ready to discuss manga anime and teach
you the right way to watch anime and not
end up like week on over to you week on
[Music]
yes and while soul is being created last
what while Seoul is being so
self-righteous I teach him how to
properly pronounce names in Japanese so
you know he's not perfect neither is he
yeah yeah mi casa es su casa recon to
you anyways what up dis recon you know I
am I do the reactions seasonal yeah so
on and I do them top tens quality top
tens that everybody likes so subscribe
if you knew go ahead I don't give a [ __ ]
really hash tag recon no Picou hash tag
havoc no pico you can call me any of
them out oh and give a [ __ ] and yeah
that's about it that was clearly a
scripted speech yes yes he planned this
off yeah he was writing the whole time
while while we were giving us anything
I haven't been writing anything bro well
yeah I got his watch the admin everyone
in the chat everyone will join us here
today we're back again next week
Thursday 5:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
all the time here having a great great
time saying time a lot as well and until
next time
dammit see you space cowboys I love you
bang Shemp aku